and now we have prague um
uh who's going to be playing the next
the next champions chester event i think
he's only 15
third youngest gm of all time and
the winner of the first uh challengers
event that was i think a couple of weeks
ago
so he's obviously gonna be a very strong
opponent and he goes for the london
wow that was unexpected
what should i do let let me go for my
old
old favorite that one
the system that
oh seriously i actually run i've
actually run into this
in some banter blitz before
so annoying okay whatever
it's not it's not that this line is
absolutely great for white it's just
that
i was hoping to play a more classical
game
but you can't you can't uh
always get what you want uh what should
i do a6 preparing b5 maybe
trying to stay flexible maybe d5 is a
move
i guess i can take it d5
97 i guess e4 you can go e4 now as well
yeah whatever we're trying to
trying to play a complicated game here
but
i have a feeling uh
considering the strength of my opponent
in this particular game
that i may may eventually
regret it or i may not you know
um anyway what i'm doing here is
somewhat artificial but if i can get
moves like knight g6 and b4 i should be
fine
and a3 feels a little bit soft to me
now we'll go b4 next to
develop my bishop with tempo and if da6
there's always fa6
e5 is not on the cards because in knight
d5 and if knight d2
i will probably castle
and uh look to the future with uh at
least com
some confidence so bishop c4 was
probably clever
um now if bishop
c3 queen c3 knight e4
there is um
there's queen g7
then i can give a check on g5 also ed5
is possible
85 bishop t5 queen g5
doesn't quite seem to work okay i guess
i'll just castle
if fe 6 fe 6 bishop e6
maybe i can sack the queen could be
but i think i'll just go king h8 and
with my lead in development
um it seems fine with threats of knight
e4 as well
so quite logically he doesn't go for it
uh but obviously i need to speed up
okay we'll go h5 i think if e5 know t4
is fine
um but i'm a little bit worried that
my attack on the queen's side is
no not really getting going
queen e4 i think
oh i just plundered
oh oh oh huge huge
damage factor here bishop f3
d7 it's nothing
cd6 then knight e5 if rook b8
ed6 seems to win
if d5 there's bishop d5
i guess i have to go for it we could he
could have just taken back on d6
okay now maybe i have some chances here
now
worst case i'll try and flag him
in a dirty way
i'm teaching the kids about chess not
manners
the more you think buddy the happier i
am
especially when you come up with a line
that gives me a decent position
this is gonna it's gonna go down to the
wire
this one
obviously right now there's there isn't
a lot of time to
it was an ideal to have to drop the
knife back but
right now it comes down to hustle okay
there's a fork
push buff two i think
we'll threaten mate because why not
oh that's why not dammit
playing really sluggishly here okay
let's go for this pawn
you can't think you can't be thinking
bishop c3 it was was there okay we'll
change
and then flag why was that
move not
oh okay he was too slow
he played very well but he was too slow
i don't know
i felt like there was a at some point
there was a glitch there